it's time for roses and rose
sarah thank you for being here you
seemed to leave last night both because
of your dad's battle with als
and because of your interactions with
the women what would you say was the
biggest factor
my family my family has to come first
you said that your dad might only have
weeks to live
so people at home wondered well why did
you ever go on the show if you were that
worried
if you're familiar with als you really
have no idea it's a steady
decline and so i had the full support of
my parents
and they wanted me to go out and to
pursue love and to do something that
you know would make me happy and make
make them happy i also
thought i would be able to communicate
with my parents and you know
have you know access to a phone and to
talk with them and
some of those things you know turned out
differently once i got there
what was it like to watch last night's
episode back
calculating calculated and manipulative
toxic and i concur you're all three of
those things sarah
i just felt like it was a firing squad
of mean comments
and i wouldn't wish that on my worst
enemy
do you see that you look like alexis
from shit's creek
like oh my god i feel like we do look
alike do you have an impression of her
that you can give us
ew david ew david
that was really good